so who's fighting who in Yemen and how
long has it been going on for well it's
been going on for far too long roughly
about a decade and it involves two main
groups a whole host of of groups within
Yemen but two main groups first the
houthi rebels who control large sways of
the north and are controlling two-thirds
of the population and they are funded
supported and get help from Iran one of
the big Regional powers in this area the
other main group is the internationally
recognized government which is supported
by Saudi Arabia the other main Regional
power here and they have a coalition
which is backed by UK USA and the United
Arab Emirates and between all of those
groups they're they are responsible for
triggering one of the world's worst
humanitarian disasters and both sides
have been accused of multiple war crimes
well it cannot be underestimated just
how much of an impact it has had on
yemenis for a start the bulk of the
population is suffering from some form
of hunger starvation malnutrition
certainly in need of food Aid the
country is in the throes of one of the
world's worst humanitarian crises apart
from that it has triggered a mass
displacement of the population with
millions of yemenis having to flee their
homes to get out of the line of fire to
get out of the way of shelling or air
strikes or to just live somewhere safely
away from mines which might have been
planted and on top of that there is a
real regression in human rights with
tick tockers instagrammers YouTube
influencers just this week being
sentenced to between six months and
three years in prison for criticizing
the houthis journalists being threatened
with execution for criticizing the
houthis there have been allegations of
war crimes on both sides so it's had a
big impact on the people of Yemen
thank you
first of all let's start on an
optimistic note because Yemen is the
closest it's ever been to any possible
peace deal for the last 10 eight years
because Iran and Saudi Arabia the two
Regional Powers who have been butting
heads and fueling this war for the last
eight to ten years have agreed to renew
diplomatic ties but even if peace was
declared today tomorrow the next day
How likely is peace to break out inside
Yemen given the proliferation of weapons
given the differing rival groups armed
groups and given their different
motivations for influence inside the
country it doesn't look hopeful that
it's going to be easy to sort out all
those rivalries entering the war and
starting a war so much easier than
ending it